Serbia's accession negotiations are
moving forward last week as you know
during the intergovernmental conference
further two chapters were opened
bringing the total to 16 chapters opened
and to provisionally closed and I
strongly believe that we could proceed
even faster and let me be very clear we
welcomed enormous Lee and I welcome the
personal commitment of Prime Minister
re-expressed today
Serbia's commitments to normalization of
its relations with Kosovo is also key
for the progress of accession
negotiations the European Union expects
Serbian Kosovo to swiftly deliver on
their commitment to the dialogue given
the direct link between comprehensive
normalization of relations between them
and the concrete prospects for their
European Union respective aspirations in
terms of our foreign policy our
number-one priority remains the EU
accession in those terms as as High
Representative said currently we have 16
chapters open and I I thank you for for
the support in opening two additional
chapters now in December we have two
chapters provisionally closed I also
agree with High Representative I think
that we could be more efficient in the
implementation of our reforms and in the
exercise of opening and closing the
chapters certainly this is down to us I
have to say that the when I went out
when I took over the office the the the
second key priority in terms of our
foreign policy was the first one was
easy integration the second one was
regional stability my firm belief is
that without stable region there can be
no individual country in that region
which is stable again Serbia and the
Prime Minister I would like to appeal
again to Pristina to reconsider this and
go back to where we were on the 5th of
November
talking about the regional instability
this does not benefit anyone
you